families had been gathering on what was
a football pitch to say farewell to
loved ones when an embankment above them
collapsed
we were sitting a look down and saw a
rock moving and falling towards me I
lowered my head and soon as I raised my
head again I saw a mass of Earth falling
on people I jumped from where I was
sitting but fell to the ground I got up
again but fell for the second time the
second time I fell I got stuck and I
couldn't move
yeah
despite the injuries he was one of the
lucky ones but his brother best friend
and mother are among those who died
my mom she was my mom and she is dead
it's not easy to express myself it's not
easy not easy not easy mom left us and
she died in very bad conditions if this
is how God had to call her it is his
will we cannot change it
[Applause]
many victims are still under the rubble
who is he leaving me with
[Applause]
[Music]
how will I take care of the children
cameroon's capital yarunde is one of the
wettest cities in Africa and parts of
the country have seen severe flooding in
the past few months but there was no
rain in yorunde on Sunday so for now we
want to entirely population that is a
risky Zone to stay and we are calling on
them to liberate the area for now for
the police and the jadams to do their
work with more rain forecast the
government is also urging those living
in areas at risk of landslides to move
Christina Harrison Al Jazeera